hi there I'm on my stepper here listing
the qurían I'll shut them down here okay
now I'm on my stepper probably three or
four times a week especially the days
that I don't play hockey and sometimes
like I'm home from hockey and get on a
stepper I don't know get rid of the
lactic acid my legs maybe who knows I'm
always motivated to get on my stepper
because it's a chance also to listen to
Korean so the two things kind of
reinforce each other I'm listening to of
course I turned it off but this is a
Bluetooth earphone set which is great
and in a separate video I show the
different kinds of earphones that I use
I listen right now I'm listening to
difficult content I'm picking out words
here and there and so in my strategy I'm
varying sort of dealing with some of the
basic structures of the language on the
one hand and then linking through
difficult content starting to accumulate
new words so that I'll be able to
understand more of this difficult
content already I have that sense that I
have a better sense of the definitions
or these have when words and the new
words begin I recognise more words
because the whole thing about language
learning is is noticing and the more
things you already see the more new
things you notice the more things you
already understand when you listen the
more new things you can start to notice
so I believe this strategy and it's
something I've mentioned in the past
sort of big picture on the one hand
listening to the language and then
focusing on some of the nuts and bolts
and gradually the to sort of strengthen
each other because it's not enough to
understand the structure if you have no
words to you know to use with the
structure so I it's not as if I don't
focus on grammar I do try to remind
myself of the different patterns of the
language but I also want to get foreign
language in me on one great place to do
that is right here on my stepper so
today I have to do some work around the
house again I think he might have rats
so I had to rip up my deck see if I
could find any rat droppings and while I
was do not ripping it out because the
deck is kind of in module so I can pull
it off so I had my of course my Korean
going what I was doing that and Korean
any rats listening could learn Korean ah
then my wife mentioned again my our dry
cleaning lady gonna go up there and
speak turned Korean a bit by the way I
happen to see a video with Moses allows
you going into some supermarket
somewhere in the States talking to
people in Somali and Korean and
Vietnamese very impressive what
impresses me with Moses is not only his
ability to learn languages but the
genuinely warm humble engaging
personality that he has me I'm more of a
cranky old guy matey but we all have our
personalities I think we most of us mean
well anyway so this is me on my stepper
when I finished on my step right here
I'm gonna go for about 25 minutes by the
way 25 minutes four times a week I mean
that's almost two hours right there yeah
I did my dishes other odd chores get a
lot of listening I find that reading is
better for acquiring vocabulary but you
know if you don't understand what you
hear you're nowhere so like I do a lot
of reading but even if I don't
understand I'm listening and I'm
listening to stuff that I can then read
review the words and when I'm doing that
I'm noticing I'm noticing some of the
words that I've looked up I'm noting
some of noticing some of the patterns
and all of that is sort of mutually
reinforcing and we often feel we're not
making progress
and I think language learning is sort of
a it's not a sprint it's a long distance
it's an endurance activity you have to
believe that you're going to get there
you just have to put in the time and I'm
quite confident that a month from now I
will notice a significant improvement
and hopefully three months from now
enough to write that topic exam the one
thing that scares me is writing with
Hangul I sat down a bit again tried the
type of hunger it's a lot to learn just
how the words are formed where the keys
are located on that keyboard and I
haven't even started writing the
longhand but all these things you have
to do them one slice at a time sometimes
if you look at the enormity of the task
you think you'll never get there but if
you kind of slice it a little bit at a
time
salamé fashion you know one step at a
time in fact that reminds me this
monologue is getting longer here that
reminds me when I was studying Chinese
though the famous Lausanne pn los
campeones the three famous essays
written by mao one is in praise of
Norman Bethune there isn't a Chinese
person who doesn't know the name of
Norman Bethune although most Canadians
have never heard of them Kenyan doctor
who served with the Communist army in
the late 30s and who died in China the
second essay is to serve the people way
Iranian fool and the third one is you
going east on the foolish old man who
tried to move a mountain and that story
is as follows this old man was digging
this mountain that was somehow in the
way of his rice field or something and
people came by and said you are a very
foolish man you're not gonna be able to
dig that mountain away and he said well
I'll dig for as long as I can and then
my son will dig and his son will dig and
the mountain is not going to get any
bigger so eventually we will remove that
mountain and language learning is a bit
like that there's so many words to learn
there's so much to do in terms of
getting your brain accustomed to this
new language at times it seems like an
impossible task but if you put in the
time and you stay with the process just
like that foolish old man except it
won't take generations you will get
there
one small step at a time and now I'll go
focus on my run and I'll put my attack
I will put my Korean back on here hello
here we are okay talk to you later
another thing that I do on the stuffer
is read on my iPad and of course this is
a lesson that I've already studied on
link is it here on my iPad it's not very
visible but I can look up words that I
don't know these are all my links did I
have saved can I have them refer to them
as I go through the lesson so on the
stepper is another opportunity to read